The Joe Rogan Experience how long before
Tick Tock spanned well let me tell you
what's going on with the tick tock I
have a very uh opinionated uh
explanation for what is going on with
Tick Tock okay Tick Tock was eating
silicon Valley's lunch they were they
were taking all the ad money from
Instagram from Twitter from Google I'd
say Google and Instagram and Facebook
just killing it Knocking it out of the
[__] Park
so look at who is
uh saying oh it's a China and they're
tracking everything and it's a Communist
Party dude
Facebook tracks you Google Tracks you
everyone [__] tracks you
all over the place but all of a sudden
Tick Tock is a problem no it's because
they're eating their lunch and instead
of competing because you know they've
tried no one can seem to create the tick
tock algorithm and the the thing that
they have going there it's what people
want the quick hits the sing-alongs Etc
so they decided to Lobby politicians and
uh and come up with this this scam so
it's Holly it's Marco Rubio oh no this
is China [__] no it's because Silicon
Valley couldn't compete with them that's
what's going on interesting oh yeah
that's an interesting just look at I
know a lot about the advertising
business because I you know I ran
companies that were in that there was so
everyone was buying Tick Tock no and you
know when you have a big company like
Facebook or Google who are tied into
um government you know how many times
have they been to to DC to explain what
they're doing and you know so that's all
controlled that's the only Avenue they
have to compete is to you got to get
these guys out of here here and good
luckily there even those American
companies that run it it's China
so now I'm not a China fan but this is a
[__] scam they are they are just
taking them down to get rid of the
competition it's real it's very sad
that's interesting because they're not
taking them down right still up oh they
will you think so oh yeah actually oh
yeah it's already you know it's banned
at UT you can't you can't have tick tock
on your phone but it's the same time
there is a real problem with the terms
of service at the same time I see what
you're saying and I see why they would
want to do that but they have an
extraordinarily invasive software how
it's no different from any other app
that you have on your phone disagree no
so you think that all of the other apps
can track your keystrokes on other
computers [__] yeah computers are not
even connected to that yeah yeah oh yeah
but
interesting interesting so why why
doesn't Apple kick it off because people
use it if if Apple doesn't have Tick
Tock people will actually give up their
iPhones they're not going to kick it off
now what Apple did if you remember they
changed some things in the way in what
they allow apps to do and that that took
about 10 billion dollars off of uh
Facebook's uh income yes because they
couldn't they couldn't sell the
information that way anymore right and
they were mad and Tick Tock is less
interested in selling your information
they're getting the ad dollars so people
it just it's it's continuous ad money
the whole thing is a big ad everything's
an ad yeah if you're gonna like
Zuckerberg like you can't use an iPhone
huh
what do you mean I mean if if Apple did
that to his company and then you know
made it so that they lost that much
money and advertising Revenue by
changing some well not advertising they
were basically selling your information
yeah and creating profiles and they all
do it I mean that's why I have the
graphene OS you know I I yeah I've had
this phone for a while I just don't I
don't this is a different one than you
had before the one you had you had an
old iPhone no no no and then you went to
a pixel so so we basically rip all the
Google stuff off and this is the the six
I had the four it was just time to
upgrade you know this screen was
cracking it's falling apart
um and yeah um as you if you're
connected to a network you're still yeah
you still know where you are yeah but
the apps cannot spy on me I know what
the apps are doing I can they're running
a Sandbox so nothing goes in or out
unless I give it that permission that's
graphene OS yeah yeah no agendaphone.com
instructions are right there on how to
do it so you think that
most of the applications are they just
not telling you the truth about what
they're allowed to do with the terms and
the permission people don't care but are
they is it written in there and no one's
paying attention to it or is it just
they're not putting that stuff in there
because what what I'm saying is that at
least it says in tick tock's terms like
what it's outrageous but some of it is
like you monitoring your keystrokes and
having access to your microphones and
stuff like that yeah they all have it
they all have that why would they not do
it but it was also the one of the points
of concern for some people was that it
was linked to computers that aren't even
loaded up with Tick Tock like they're
not even connected
[Music]
everything is tracked we're in there's
only one telephone company is the US
government they have everything
everything is recorded everything that
you put on a Network anywhere goes into
in Utah they've got the big uh data
centers you know they're all cooled
under Waters all kinds of high-tech [__]
and whenever they need to find out what
Joe Rogan's doing uh let's pull up Rogan
did he uh did he uh text Curry on Signal
what day was it it just comes up right
comes up that signal they I mean
encryption is a problem which you know
is a problem for for the government
um uh but again you know how many
companies just give up the goods Apple
does maybe 30 000 a month or something I
mean you know what do you need we'll
give it to you they pay for it the FBI
pays we know that from the Twitter files
you know it's like hey we need uh
information on this account okay that's
five thousand dollars and well okay no
problem we'll just pay I'm these numbers
are making them up right there were
millions of dollars that they paid
Twitter just for handing over account
information I think
Twitter never really collected though
is that true I'm pretty sure that's true
well Facebook certainly did and Google
certainly does and they publish those
numbers they publish the numbers that
they that they I don't know where but I
think that was a part of that narrative
because you know there was a giant bill
that uh that uh
the FBI had owed Twitter it was like
three million dollars yeah yeah
apparently they never paid find out if
that's true well they're they're coaches
what the hell yeah FBI you bastards to
the USA Today oh there we go USA Today
well let's see what we got no this is
this is the right message you want to
know what USA Today two separate events
okay first the documents released by new
Twitter owner Elon Musk showed that the
FBI flag Twitter accounts the agency
believe violated Twitter's terms of
service second another document shows
the FBI paid Twitter 3.4 million dollars
for Twitter's processing of information
requests the FBI made through a stored
Communications act the 3.4 million is
unrelated to the FBI flagging accounts
yeah that's unrelated but it's also like
we're giving you a lot of money it's
unrelated yeah but did they actually pay
the money that was the question well I
think you can look at this paying for
account information uh because the
Silicon Valley company is like well
we're not going to do this work for free
you got to pay we got to put people on
it right so it's normal but if they
didn't pay it off that's that's [__]
up that's [__] up are they going to
give it to Elon like how does that work
if they did but I don't drop in the
bucket maybe someone erroneously
reported that and I just read it I think
what we're seeing with Twitter
what we're seeing with Twitter is it was
not a very profitable con company you
know kind of ran a little bit it takes a
lunatic to spend 44 billion dollars to
get a not very profitable company so
that he can let people just talk [__]
well I think he's doing more I think he
is and I'm not sure
um I listened to uh the converse someone
sent me the clip of you and him about
four years ago talk about Ai and how
that's going to take over the world and
how he tried to stop it and now he seems
to be all in on it
um but I I think that's his x.com which
is what he wanted PayPal to be and that
didn't turn out the way he wanted and
he's literally said I want it to be like
WeChat I mean he has said that I want to
be your bank I want to be your social
that app you use super app he calls it a
super app that's what he's doing and of
course with that once you have
authenticated everybody with a real name
you don't need trust and safety you you
know if someone does something bad it's
that person right and we can send the
feds on them or the feds can find go
themselves or you know you can have a
lawyer sue you if you say something
slanderous yeah but it will be the thing
that you use like in China for
everything and that he said that so it's
his words and
um so it behooves them to to keep as
many people on the platform by just
letting it open you know I'm it's
beautiful to watch
um
I don't know if he's if he's
overextended himself a little bit on the
on the on the cost of it
um it's costing him a lot you know it's
costing him in uh in value and Tesla
stock value and he seems to be okay with
that which is is great we'll see I mean
it's it's a it's a big nut to crack to
do that to to create the the WeChat of
of America or the rest of the world
but then I see like starlink which to me
was I mean starlink was what a amazing
[__] invention I have it at home like
you put this [__] dish on the ground
and I got internet and it's fast and
it's groovy but of course where does the
real money come in now it's a it's a
military system
which I think was probably the plan all
along I mean it's great to to give
consumers this for 110 a month
um but when you have the military and
that came out of Ukraine you know how he
he said hey you should pay me for this
and they went no [__] you you should do
this just because you're a good guy and
you know after a while he's like you
know I'm moving satellites around you
should probably pay me to do this as a
service and I forget what it's called
but it is now an actual government
military service that that is used in
the field it is kind of bizarre that a
country can say you should just kind of
hook us up that was the US government
saying that the US government was saying
that this is what I've found about that
okay here it goes a former Facebook
Security executive has called Elon Musk
claim that the FBI paid Twitter to
moderate content false Alex Stamos and
this is what we were talking about
earlier
um that it was that you you can't like
say that this is exactly why they did it
uh
not what I said no no no I'm not saying
you did
um comment comes after journalist
Michael schellenberger shared a redacted
screenshot of a 2021 email showing that
Twitter had collected over 3.4 million
from a reimbursement program for time
spent processing FBI requests
that was just information requests it
wasn't re-platforming requests I totally
agree with that I agree with that too
but you also could recognize that if
there is a deal where compensation is
being paid to your company to tune a 3.4
million dollars like that's a
significant it's a business transaction
but it it was because of you know tens
of thousands of accounts that had the
information had to be collected given to
the FBI completely separate from
politicians saying you need to look at
this guys you know they're against your
own terms and service against what fauci
says take them down flag them deep you
know uh don't uh amplify them that's
that's the egregious part that has
nothing to do with the FBI as far as I'm
okay if you look at I think we talked
about this in 2000
maybe 2010 or 12. Mark Zuckerberg was
Man of the Year and he was on the cover
of Time Magazine and if you read that
article don't let that happen okay if
you read that article in the middle of
this interview
Robert Mueller FBI director pops his
head in hey I was just I just happened
to be in the building I just wanted to
say hi everybody and even the reporter
who wrote This Time magazine article
says it was the most bizarre [__]
thing I've ever seen the FBI was already
in these companies from inception they
were already for the collection it's a
beautiful system people post pictures
you know there's your location and like
here I am you know it's ah beautiful why
wouldn't you want that as an
intelligence organization but they were
in then and Robert Mueller who it must
have been 2012 because
um they extended him for a couple
against the Constitution which is really
funny because he's only supposed to be
there for 10 years after the you know
the FBI has assorted history and there
was a a very solid law put in place no
FBI director can be FBI director more
than 10 years except
Robert Mueller was in for an extra two
years for some reason because whatever
when Obama came in well we need this guy
and he was in faith literally in the
Facebook building oh it just happened to
be in the building the director of the
FBI come on that was you know so they've
been there for a long long time that is
bizarre um thank you Jamie oh Dynamite
so much this is great Joe it's so fun to
talk to you brother I'm good we
shouldn't clarify what that actually
said though one of the things that's
interesting he said uh so this is a
mastodon thread uh so uh this guy Stamos
who left Facebook in 2018 to lecture at
Stanford explained that law enforcement
has the ability to get stored
Communications from companies like
Twitter under 18 USC 273 D this Infamous
d-order has to be signed by a judge he
said that uh out of the companies can
demand reimbursement for the request
which is what Twitter did
oh no oh no they almost got us he said
uh you can companies can demand
reimbursement for the request which is
what Twitter did though prior to 2019 as
shown by the email screenshot the
company chose not to yeah so they chose
not to get reimbursement prior to 2019.
so for a while they were doing it for
free they were doing the yeah it becomes
expensive Google has always charged them
for it you know I think Apple was
charging for and they published those
numbers it just is not it's so weird
it's all part of the distraction to keep
us guessing and whatever you do keep
posting selfies we need you to keep
posting selfies keep letting us know
what you're doing